[Music]
hope everybody had a great fourth of
july weekend but now we're here we're
ready to get back down to business we're
here to refuel and treat our bodies
right that's exactly why we teamed up
with celebrity fitness trainer and tv
host amanda klutz as well as smart water
for rehydration day first of all how was
your long weekend oh my gosh my weekend
was so great it was filled with family
and fun festivities activities all the
good but we're back here down to
business today because we really need to
focus on rehydrating our body you know
that's why i love smart water it's
filled with electrolytes it makes it
taste refreshing and crisp and pure
exactly what you need on a hot summer
day and listen before you work out it's
always important to hydrate your body so
let's get some water okay let's
rehydrate right away cheers
oh so good you know i love taking your
class you're you're the fitness expert
i'm hoping that you can help kind of
recenter me after a long weekend you
know i got you can you show me a few of
your moves yes let's do it
so we're going to do some lower body
work today okay but you know me i kind
of incorporate everything all at once so
you're going to be going
you're going to be on your left leg your
right leg is going to be kind of out to
the side abs in tight booty underneath
arms stretch nice and long so that we
tone our upper body as well you're gonna
come back to a curtsy squat squeezing
your inner thighs stretch up lengthen
through your quad squeeze those glutes
come back down and then come back up to
where you started this is a really great
way to work those inner thighs sometimes
you know we have a hard time targeting
that muscle and so it's really good to
really think about squeezing those legs
as tight as you possibly can i mean
honestly if you wanted to make it more
cardio you could pick and you know speed
up your pace if you like
or you can take it as slow as you need
lengthen through those arms every single
one is burning last one
move number one done time to rehydrate
smart idea you know i've been
incorporating smart water during my
workouts pre-workout post-workout for
years but smart water alkaline has a
higher ph level than regular smart water
it makes the perfect workout buddy well
that sounds fantastic we should take a
sip i think so cheers
i'm feeling good are you ready for move
number two let's do it let's go
all right we're gonna come forward with
our left leg again down into kind of
like a deep lunge you're gonna work your
hamstrings and your glutes on this one
all right tightening the back of the leg
abs in tight keep your left leg bent so
we work our quads on the left leg here
we go we're gonna press forward kick
back on that right leg strengthening
those glutes and lengthening your
hamstring let's do four of them so
that's two
back down again three
and down and your abs are working too
because you have to stabilize as you
come up and down it's a full body
workout that focuses on your legs but
you really feel everything totally here
we go down and stretch and kick back
and up keep your balance okay and two
abs in tight give me one more and come
back down about to start shaking yes all
right so let's talk about it we did our
inner thighs we did our hamstrings and
our glutes yes
so now we got to do our outer thighs
right this area right here oh it's tough
to target but it is you can do it you
know i gotta move for you okay left leg
bent ankle to ankle kind of open up your
right knee again we're gonna focus on
stabilizing through our abs and you're
just going to lift your leg up and down
in kind of what i call an attitude
position you know gotta use those dancer
terms i'm just gonna say you have me
feeling like uh i'm empowered to go
audition for i don't know the ballet
and again if you needed extra help for
stabilization you could have a chair in
front of you easy easy way to modify you
did not come to play today amanda don't
you worry we are almost at a rehydration
water break so don't you worry give me
two more give me one more
yay
i earned it come
on you earned it listen with smart water
workouts feel good
this water tastes good sure does
life is good cheers
[Music]